you tweet a lot you're very funny in
your tweets you recently tweeted about
me I've done a few times yes you have
recently this was quite recently this
was just a few days ago oh and this yeah
hey man I photographed your sperm under
a microscope that's what you wanted a
sperm for Howard Hughes yeah just you
never know I just love that my sperm is
Reds bright orange squirrels 2007 was a
good year yeah you thoroughly enjoyed
Twitter you're quite good at what's your
favorite Twitter exchange so far you
like to get into it with people jealous
with them a lot I sometimes look just
for just for math research for someone
to do it it's lovely the distraction and
and there's so many stupid people on
Twitter it's great yeah someone said hey
you're worth 80 million but you haven't
had your teeth fixed and I send back
when you're this rich you get your
Butler to chew your food now you you
took some health advice cuz Gwyneth
Paltrow is obviously a big deal in
social media you took health advice from
her she has a site doesn't sometimes she
says crazy things and she's not a doctor
but she she has told she's it does she
see it she advised people to steam their
vagina oh yeah yes that's face she did
say that she said that women
specifically not know that she said
women should which should steam that
area of their body whoa okay go yeah you
gave it a go yeah you gave it a go you
brought a you brought a video I think so
let's take a look
[Laughter]
that's about all of that that I can
handle now I can't tell I can't tell are
you enjoying that or are you not
enjoying that it was it was more joy
than I thought that's it looks like a
man who's enjoying something doesn't it
you